karla wrote in do you ever exhibit OCD
behaviors in other words obsessive
compulsive behaviors I really don't I
really don't I I think I had a Fae a
couple phases in my life where I had
something sort of like that like one
thing that I remember is it would often
happen that as I was leaving a room
where the light was on I would sort of
flip the light switch off and you know
how sometimes you can flip a light
switch where you kind of push it and you
don't actually make contact with it all
the way into the on position you just
kind of flick it and the light does turn
off so by all reasonable standards the
switch is fully in the off position I
would get it into my head what if the
light is off but the switch is kind of
stuck halfway and imagine if in the
middle of the night as a result of
having been left in this halfway
position a spark causes a fire so I
would go back in and actually look at
the switch to make sure that it was
fully in the opposition now when I've
told people this in conversations about
OCD they've said David that's not really
OCD that's sort of like making sure that
your stove is off before you leave your
apartment or something like that it's
sort of basic safety but I started to
feel as though it was bordering on in my
head being an OCD type behavior I also
used to have this thing where I would
want to when I'd go to bed at night I'd
want to read I wouldn't necessarily want
to read for exactly half an hour but I
would check the time and I would tell
myself the how half-hour mark is at X
time so if I went to bed at 11:30 I'd be
like okay midnight is the half hour mark
it wouldn't necessarily mean anything
like sometimes I'd be dozing off before
that sometimes I wouldn't be tired and I
read way past that but I would always
want to know when is the half hour mark
of me getting into bed and reading I
don't know why I was doing that and
eventually I told myself I think this is
kind of like an OCD type behavior I'm
just not going to do it anymore
and I stopped doing it and right now I
really don't feel like I have any of
those types of behaviors just things
that we do every day you get into a
routine and you kind of want to stick to
it and for your light switch example I
have a very similar thing where even
after I look
my car or my apartment I make sure to
open the door again or at least try to
develop the lock actually went through
and as you know that's just protecting
my stuffs I'd say yeah I think it's
necessarily an OCD type thing right yeah
that's right and I mean obviously you
you count the number of tires twelve
times on your car before you walk away
with yeah it might be a little more in
the OCD direction I do wash my hands but
not obsessively yeah maybe
once twice a week yeah yeah I don't I'm
pretty comfortable saying right now that
uh I don't have these types of
tendencies but I guess at some point in
my life I kind of did I know a lot of
people who have these tendencies they
have things with like even numbers they
never set their alarm to any odd time
like if they need to get up at 7:05
they'd set it for 700 or 706 I don't
like the number nine okay that's weird
because it's not ten you know yeah like
it perfectly if you wanted a lot of
strange do you know people who have
really serious OCD type behaviors
oh I don't know you don't know probably
you probably do okay alright Pat not
saying well anyway Carla yeah I wish I
had something more interesting but I
guess the answer is not really